sage et à tous bienvenue au musée
national de l'histoire de l'immigration
palais de la porte dorée dans cette
émission nous allons nous intéresser à
l'immigration depuis des années l'europe
est confrontée à une pression migratoire
de plus en plus forte émission spéciale
reportages et décryptage des
journalistes de la rédaction
dans cette émission direction calais
c'est une ville symbole de l'échec des
politiques migratoires européennes ait
ensuite en allemagne un des pays
d'europe qui accueille le plus de
réfugiés pour garantir ce fameux modèle
allemand face à une population
vieillissante mais d'abord direction
malmö en suède
là bas comme partout en europe la
communauté juive souffre d'un regain
d'antisémitisme et pense de plus en plus
à la halle via l'installation en israël
c'est quoi le bouffard qui nous en
parlent comme dans cette le texte vous
êtes vous rendu en suède
rappelez-vous n'aura les 14 et 15
février dernier d attentat frappe la
capitale danoise copenhague deux morts
cinq blessés
d'abord devant un centre culturel et
puis devant une synagogue en plein
shabbat les attentats qui font écho à
ceux de paris alors face à ces actes
antisémites on a voulu nous rendre
compte du climat dans lequel vivaient
les communautés juives d'europe je me
suis rendu à malmö rencontré cette
petite communauté juive qui vivent dans
la peur est un peu caché chaque matin le
même rituel
déborah et simon emmènent leur fils à
l'école un rituel perturbé sur le chemin
ils sont sur leurs gardes
par précaution ils ont souhaité garder
l'anonymat
la famille est de confession juive
la différence maintenant c'est qu'on ne
peut plus rester devant l'école juive
on est plus en sécurité
ça fait vraiment bizarre de savoir que
notre enfant n'est plus en sécurité
juste parce qu'il est juif
une école juive
une centaine d'enfants sous haute
protection policière en plein centre de
malmö la troisième ville de suède
ici on est à quelques kilomètres de
copenhague au danemark
il ya quelques semaines deux attaques
terroristes vous le verse le pays
la seconde vise une synagogue danoise en
plein shabbat
un agent de sécurité tué depuis en suède
on renforce la sécurité devant les
institutions juives des policiers
suréquipés sont déployés
rise elle est enseignante ici à l'école
depuis les attentats plusieurs parents
ont retiré leurs enfants de
l'établissement
je pense que c'est la peur police en
sensuelles les écoles maternelles les
écoles primaires rien n'est fermé
tout est ouvert fin des sorties
scolaires les enfants sont cloîtrés à
l'intérieur des classes ils ne vont même
plus à la bibliothèque l'insécurité
grandit devant l'école
hors caméra une mère de famille nous
interpelle elle nous le confie sa peur
et si grande qu'elle prévoit de quitter
la suède pour israël d'ici quinze jours
malmö c'est trois cent mille habitants
le symbole du multiculturalisme à la
suédoise où se côtoient près de 175
communautés différentes
un exemple de vivre ensemble une société
ouverte et sur qui voit l'antisémitisme
grandir
face à ce constat s'est adjoint au maire
a dû prendre des mesures particulières
surveillance caméra bien sûr des gardes
de sécurité devant les juifs
devant la synagogue c'est bien sûr la la
toute première chose que l'on devait
faire et à le faire dans l'urgence
ensuite dans un second temps et vient à
bulles en termes on doit sensibiliser
les jeunes alain sémitisme bien sûr ça
prend du temps mais ce temps vraiment le
prendre
au stade de malmö séances de
sensibilisation aux religions vous savez
qui est sur la photo les us we midi
quelqu'un d'autre avec lui résident toi
là-bas il ya aussi judas des dizaines de
jeunes toutes confessions confondues
sont réunies le comité suédois contre
l'antisémitisme se mobilisent il faut
mettre des mots sur le racisme souvent
l'antisémitisme est suggéré
sous-entendu il faut que les professeurs
et enseignants soient capables de parler
de ça soit capable de contrer ses idées
ils ont besoin des connaissances de base
comment l'antisémitisme se propage
aujourd'hui et notamment sur internet
les jeunes passent beaucoup de temps le
rabbin kesselman subit régulièrement des
attaques
il y encore deux jours il est pris à
partie par des jeunes qui l'insultent en
pleine rue que pense-t-il du premier
ministre israélien benyamin nétanyahou
qui appelle les juifs d'europe à faire
leur alyah leur retour en israël pour
trouver la sécurité
je pense qu'il fait son travail de
premier ministre en informant les juifs
sont un endroit sécurisé à venir vivre
je pense que c'est une sonnette d'alarmé
pour les communautés européennes
aujourd'hui il y aurait environ 1500
suédois de confession juive à malmö en
la police a enregistré 137 plainte pour
antisémitisme une augmentation de 30%
sur les deux dernières années comme on
voit clairement votre reportage que les
suédois se mobilisent pour maintenir ce
multiculturalisme
j'ai rencontré sofia nerbrand c'est une
suédoise qui n'est pas de confession
juive
elle a créé l'équipe a walk les marches
à la kippa des manifestations dans la
rue pour dénoncer les actes antisémites
alors juifs et non-juifs portent tous
des kippa sur la tête
sofiane ledit l'antisémitisme à malmö
est un peu un test crucial pour
l'ensemble du pays pour le pour la suède
pour l'avenir du multiculturalisme mais
on voit bien depuis quelques années
aussi l'augmentation dans les urnes de
l'extrême droite
effectivement le parti démocrate suédois
mais aujourd'hui c'est la troisième
force politique du pays c'est un parti
nationaliste il a doublé son score aux
législatives il est passé de 5,7 pour
cent il ya quatre ans à 12% aujourd'hui
49 députés de ce parti au parlement et à
chaque incident et bien ce parti dénonce
la politique d'immigration du
gouvernement suédois
et qu'en est il de la communauté juive
envoie dans votre reportage que vous
avez rencontré cette femme c'est parents
qui cherchait à a quitté la suède pour
israël c'est une mère de famille qui est
né en suède
elle a trop peur pour ses enfants est là
depuis quelques jours elle est en israël
a quitté la suède
alors ces personnes qui répondent à un
appel des dirigeants israéliens qui
appelle bas tous ces juifs d'europe à
faire leur alyah leur retour en israël
pour fuir le terrorisme et le danger en
europe
et bien pourtant aujourd'hui si on
regarde les chiffres il n'y a pas
d'effet 9 janvier et notamment en france
par rapport à 2014
c'est une baisse de 20% des retours vers
israël merci paul si les communautés
cherchent à quitter l'europe d'autres
veulent ils trouvé refuge notamment les
syriens les erythréens les soudanais les
somaliens qui fuient la guerre beaucoup
d'entre eux se retrouvent à calais dans
l'attenté d'un passage en angleterre
c'est mounir soucis qui nous en parle
mounir vous vous êtes rendu à calais à
l'automne dernier alors que la question
d'une migration revenait sur le devant
de la scène
oui on a trouvé intéressant de se rendre
à calais pour prendre le pouls sur cette
question calais qui est la ville
emblématique sur la problématique des
migrants est arrivé sur place on s'est
aperçu qu'une tension était en train de
renaître sur la zone après une période
de relative accalmie en termes de flux
de migrants et donc les politiques se
sont ré emparer et réapproprier la
question ce qui a fait réémerger la
problématique des migrants sur la scène
politique nationale et internationale
notamment européennes
on vous suit à calais où vous avez été
avec sagna deux tiers
chaque jour des dizaines de ferries
traverse la manche calais et son port
c'est la dernière frontière avant
l'angleterre la porte de sortie de
l'espace schengen
la promesse d'une vie meilleure pour des
milliers de migrants bloqués ici
voilà l'endroit où je dors dans cette
tente comme vous pouvez voir s'est
trompé puis à fuir la foule est
nous avons peur de l'hiver parce qu'on
est physiquement faible on ne peut pas
résister à ce qu'ils méritent
we can de 7
hamad à 29 ans avant de quitter son pays
il était avocat mais il a dû fuir le
darfour région soudanaise en guerre
depuis 2003 où sa vie était menacée l'an
dernier qu'elle ait compté environ 300
migrants
ils sont aujourd'hui plus de 2300 comme
ahmad la plupart fui une zone de conflit
et sont donc éligibles au droit d'asile
personnellement peu importe où en europe
si j'ai une occasion je la saisirai
beaucoup se disent prêts à aller
n'importe où mais de préférence en
grande-bretagne alors on va passer de
leur côté des stations service vous
allez suivre et c'est avec un petit peu
de chance de vous montrer comment ces
gars essaient de se cacher dans les
camions
et c'est pas facile mais on estime qu'il
y en a 10 entre 10 et 50 qui arrive à
passer chaque nuit donc vous avez des
migrants qui essaient de se cacher dans
le camion mais ils ne savent pas si le
camion il rend en angleterre ou pas
kelly depuis quinze ans symbole de
l'échec des politiques migratoires en
2002 la fermeture du camp de sangatte
avait repoussé des migrants dans les
bois une jungle démantelée elle aussi en
2009 désormais dispersées dans plusieurs
camps ils ne peuvent compter que sur
l'aide des associatifs comme christian
bénévoles de l'auberge des migrants
why not
ok si calé concentre aujourd'hui autant
de migrants
natacha bouchart maire de calais en est
convaincu c'est parce que l'europe n'a
jamais harmoniser sa politique d'asile
quel est le problème européen numéro un
aujourd'hui c'est le problème du flux
migratoires c'est la stratégie qui n'a
pas été écrite c'est le manque de
contact entre pays européens
c'est le manque de solidarité en
attendant que les états européens
coopèrent les associatifs eu échanges et
s'organisent
là ça va il est chaud c'est encore flou
en grande bretagne les demandeurs
d'asile sont logés ils ont une
allocation mensuelle
la gale je suis vraiment choqué et
bouleversé car ces migrants vivent ici à
calais dans des conditions proches de
celles que j'ai vu dans les camps au
darfour
des camps de réfugiés de l'onu voire des
tentes de l'armée
la solution commence à être évoquée par
certains associatif inquiet al'approche
de l'hiver de voir les migrants dormir
dehors
mounir calais la situation depuis votre
reportage et bien quelques jours après
notre tournage le ministre de
l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve s'était
rendu sur place et s'était rendu sur
place pour annoncer l'ouverture d'un
centre d'accueil de jour pour ces
migrants qu'il a vocation à accueillir
des migrants pour qu'ils puissent se
restaurer souffler un peu mais en aucun
cas pour les héberger
cette l'idée n'était pas de refaire
sangatte en fait c'était vraiment le
contre-modèle a évité et il faut savoir
que moment où ce centre était ouvert à
calais et bien à paris des camps de
fortune étaient en train de se
construire notamment au métro la
chapelle
un camp qui a été évacué sans ménagement
début de l'été ce qui a poussé tous ces
migrants d'un petit peu aérée de kankan
dans la capitale qu'en est-il sur le
plan européen bien on a tous en tête ces
images de naufrages d'embarcations en
pleine méditerranée avec des migrants à
leur bord 2000 ont péri dans ces
conditions cette année l'italie commence
à être un petit peu fatigué d'avoir à
gérer cette situation seule et elle a
fait appel à la solidarité européenne
un appel qui n'a pas encore était très
bien entendus par les voisins notamment
la france et l'allemagne qui ont demandé
à l'italie de maîtriser ses frontières
et de garder les migrants sur son sol ce
qui a donné lieu à des situations de
tension à la frontière franco italienne
à vintimille où des policiers français
se sont redéployés le long de la
frontière pour procéder à des contrôles
et refouler les migrants en désaccord
total avec les accords de schengen
merci beaucoup monnières l'allemagne
depuis 2013 a mis en place un programme
innovant de réinstallation de réfugiés
syriens qu'ils vont directement chercher
dans des camps libanais une forme des
migrations choisi c'est jérôme bonnard
qui nous en parle
jérôme qui sont ces réfugiés que vous
allez rencontrer en allemagne alors en
allemagne donc je me suis rendu dans un
camp de réfugiés africains dans la basse
saxe à au sud de hanovre
ces réfugiés syriens sont arrivés par
vols charters directement du liban c'est
une forme de réinstallation c'est à dire
qu'ils vont à l'issue de leur passage
dans le camp obtenir un titre de séjour
valide deux ans donc ils sont là pour
participer un petit peu aussi à
l'économie du pays et bana et syrienne
elle a 8 ans il y a quelques jours elle
vivait encore au liban avec ses petits
camarades dans des camps de réfugiés
beaucoup sont nés pendant la guerre il
découvre pour la première fois les joies
de l'école au programme un apprentissage
intensif et sur mesure de la langue de
goethe
car désormais leur terre d'accueil c'est
l'allemagne
en fait on évite de parler avec les
enfants de ce qu'ils ont vécu là bas on
ne parle que de choses positives
ils apprennent vite grâce à une méthode
ludique et positive ces petits réfugiés
et leurs familles sont arrivés mi
février
il reste deux semaines dans ce centre
d'hébergement comme eux ils sont chaque
mois une centaine à venir du liban ils
font partie d'un programme humanitaire
contrairement aux demandeurs d'asile ils
obtiennent dès leur arrivée un permis de
séjour de deux ans car l'onu tire la
sonnette d'alarmé les camps aux
frontières syriennes sont saturés 3,8
millions de syriens ont fui la guerre
près d'un million et demi vivre au liban
alors lagence demande aux pays riches et
notamment à l'europe de faire un effort
pour aider ces réfugiés et laqueur 7h
bien grâce à dieu je me sens très bien
je suis en sécurité
je remercie tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à
venir
dès l'arrivée les familles sont prises
en charge cours de langue informations
générales sur la vie en allemagne
de quoi préparer la nouvelle vie qui les
attend le centre de friedland est située
à une centaine de kilomètres au sud de
hanovre ici transit des réfugiés du
monde entier savamment garçon tu as bien
travaillé je compte en callas doit s'y
menahem et leurs parents sont syrien ils
ont été sélectionnés par l'onu grâce aux
programmes humanitaires allemands
pour eux c'est une délivrance
au liban c'est simple on n'avait pas
d'avenir
et si on était resté en syrie cela
aurait été encore pire
regardez mon petit garçon il n'a jamais
vu l'école jamais eu de livre il a
appris un peu d'anglais il ya un peu
d'arabe
mais c'est tout aujourd'hui je ne peux
pas imaginer rentrer en syrie
un jour on aura sûrement le mal du pays
mais pour l'instant notre vie est ici la
famille balla partira bientôt
s'installer dans la région de dusseldorf
les parents pourront travailler depuis
vingt mille réfugiés syriens font partie
de ces programmes d'admission temporaire
l'allemagne a fourni près de 400
millions d'euros dans l'aide humanitaire
pour répondre à la crise syrienne
loin devant les autres pays d'europe la
france a promis seulement 1000 places
d'ici fin 2015
l'allemagne qui voit sa population
vieillir se distingue en europe par sa
générosité
mais jusqu'où le peut-elle
via bien sûr évidemment des limites
vous savez on ne compte pas accueillir
quand même des centaines milliers de
demandeurs d'asile
ici sur notre sol en allemagne un
dossier tenir compte de ces programmes
d'admission temporaire des programmes
qui prévoit d'ailleurs près de 20000
places sinon il y aura des problèmes de
logistique ne serait ce que pour les
loger et pour les intégrer dans la
société
le pays accueille déjà avec la suède
près de la moitié des demandes d'asile
de syriens en europe en dehors des
programmes humanitaires
aujourd'hui il demande aux autres
membres de faire des efforts on a vu les
images des réfugiés naufragés de van
lente et 12 ha et les gens disent bien
sûr qu'il faut faire quelque chose alors
on peut le faire il faut le faire
pourquoi on ne fait pas ou lhimer la
large demande d'asile programme
d'admission temporaire
au total quelque 80000 syriens sont
entrés en allemagne depuis le début de
la guerre
selon l'onu trois cent quatre-vingt
mille réfugiés identifié comme
vulnérable nécessite d'être accueilli e
aussi par les pays riches
jérôme il existe plusieurs programmes de
réinstallation de réfugiés en europe
quelle est la particularité de celui ci
alors celui qu'on a vu dans le reportage
d'un programme de réinstallation des
missions humanitaires propres à
l'allemagne
c'est à dire que les réfugiés sont plus
ou moins sélectionnés et ils viennent
directement des camps de réfugiés qui
sont proches de la syrie notamment au
liban en turquie l'allemagne fait ça
depuis 2013 ils ont promis 30000 places
de réinstallation entre 2013 et 2015 et
il ya un autre programme consistant la
relocalisation quelle est la différence
alors la relocalisation concerne les
migrants qui sont sur le territoire
européen
l'idée c'est de ces de les répartir au
sein des 28 selon des clés des critères
ça peut être le taux de chômage du pays
d'accueil son pib
sa santé économique tout simplement en
fait réelle division parce qu'il ya des
pays qui sont d'accord d'autres qui ne
sont pas du tout d'accord comme les
britanniques par exemple
donc ça sera sur la base du volontariat
on parle de 60000 personnes concernées
par ces programmes
ça semble quelque peu ridicule eu égard
au nombre de réfugiés qu'on peut trouver
notamment en turquie ou au liban au
liban il ya un million 3 de réfugiés
syriens
c'est 25% de la population il a un
million c'est ton turquie donc quand on
voit ces chiffres d'ailleurs
l'onu a appelé à une réinstallation
d'environ 130 mille réfugiés d'ici fin
2016 pour le moment on a environ à 50000
places promises mais c'est pareil
entre les mots et les actes la question
se pose sur la réelle générosité de
l'europe et le pape françois a fustigé
le manque de solidarité de l'europe
pourtant une de ses valeurs cardinales
merci beaucoup l'émigration est une
solution pour l'allemagne afin de
maintenir ce fameux modèle économique
qui a fait sa force et c'est celle ci
dessous qui nous en parle c'est si l'on
prône le fameux modèle allemand est ce
que c'est justifié mais n'aura a priori
tout va bien en allemagne
c'est la première économie de la zone
euro sa croissance est bien meilleure
que celle des autres pays européens
et puis sa force ce sont ses
exportations qui ont progressé de plus
de 1 milliard d'euros en 2014
donc a priori sur le papier tout va bien
mais en réalité il ya des signes de
crise dans cette économie allemande il
ya déjà un taux de pauvreté est
extrêmement élevé il ya 12 millions de
personnes qui vivent en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté en allemagne il ya aussi des
infrastructures désuètes et l'état
n'investit plus dans ses infrastructures
l'autre point faible c'est la
démographie qui est vieillissante et qui
décroît rapidement aujourd'hui il ya 50
millions de personnes actives en
allemagne en 2060 on attend 36 millions
de personnes actives sur une population
de 80 millions de personnes
ce qui explique en fait le recours
systématique à l'immigration choisie en
allemagne
nous avons donc choisi de nous rendre
dans la région de cologne pour voir
cette économie en trompe l'oeil
ici c'est une des lames usagers enlevé
d'une machine qui nous a été envoyé et
qu'on aiguise des lames étincelante
c'est la spécialité de berne sub
guinness son grand père il ya plus de
cent ans a créé cette entreprise de
couteau aujourd'hui cette pme familiale
de cologne emploie près de 400 personnes
et exporte dans le monde entier in fact
of le facteur décisif dans la décision
de nos clients pour nos produits c'est
la qualité de l'innovation technologique
nous essayons toujours de trouver les
meilleures solutions pour répondre à de
nouveaux défis et pour le moment on y
arrive très bien miracle allemand malgré
la crise son entreprise et rester en
bonne santé
berne sub d'inès a tout fait pour ne pas
licencier outre-rhin ce sont bien les
pme qui sont la colonne vertébrale de
l'économie en allemagne
nous avons beaucoup de pme familiales
qui sont très orientées vers
l'exportation
très présente à l'international est très
active dans la recherche
elles ont su être innovante et se sont
établies sur leur marché et continue de
se développer
flexibilité du travail main d'oeuvre bon
marché avec moins de 5% de chômeurs
l'allemagne fait figure de locomotive de
l'union européenne
mais ce modèle reste fragile
yosano redressement si c'est une vieille
soudure et là c'est la nouvelle ces
brèches dans l'acier hans les connaît
par coeur depuis deux ans il colmate les
fissures du pont de leverkusen ouvrage
n'a pas résisté au passage quotidien de
milliers de camions depuis 2012 ils
n'ont plus le droit de l'emprunter le
problème principal c'est ce entre les
années 60 et aujourd'hui le trafic a
énormément de noms qui à l'époque nous
n'avions que douze mille camions et
véhicules sur le pont par jour
aujourd'hui on en a 120 me est là dedans
il faut compter 20 mille camions bus et
ça veut dire que toutes les prévisions
sont erronées du coup l'usure et la
oroya on peut refaire leur retard
faute d'investissements et d'entretien
aujourd'hui 46 % des ponts 20% des
autoroutes et 41% des routes nationales
sont dans un état critique
ce n'est pas seulement l'économie locale
mais l'économie au sens général qui
souffre beaucoup de cela selon les
estimations les pertes s'élèveraient à 1
million d'euros par jour parce que le
pont est fermé pour les camions qui
doivent alors faire un détour est passé
par les ponts du centre ville mais qui
sont eux aussi arrivés à la limite de
leurs capacités
non
le
autre réalité de l'économie allemande la
pauvreté qui touche un sixième de la
population
bonjour merci
donnez-moi quelques poivrons rouges
aussi à 56 ans des ateliers tous les
jeudis dans ce centre social sa retraite
de secrétaire ne lui permet pas de
subvenir à ses besoins
ça va je touche 900 et quelques euros je
paye 500 euros de loyer ensuite il y a
les assurances le téléphone
l'électricité donc à la fin il ne me
reste plus grand chose pour vivre et
puis que ce centre de distribution
existe nous avons remarqué que de plus
en plus de gens viennent des gens de
tous types
on voit plus de familles les aussi plus
de personnes seules en plus de personnes
âgées
mais même s'il ya des gens qui viennent
ici qui certes ont un travail mais dont
le salaire n'est pas suffisant pour
subvenir à leurs propres besoins ou à
ceux de leurs familles face à cette
réalité le gouvernement de coalition
d'angela merkel a introduit le 1er
janvier un smic horaire à 8 euros 50
avancées sociales pour certains freins
aux entreprises pour d'autres en tous
cas un enjeu de taille pour l'allemagne
qui devra lutter pour rester la première
économie européenne
cécile l'instauration du salaire minimum
at il changé quelque chose
et bien haut rhin à ce jour il n'y a pas
vraiment de bilan précis sur
l'introduction du smic en allemagne
le smic à 8 euros 50 il semblerait
toutefois que ça se passe un petit peu
dans la douleur la ministre du travail
allemand andre à nice elle a elle même
reconnu il ya beaucoup d'employeurs qui
visiblement ne jouent pas le jeu et qui
utilise un petit peu toutes les astuces
pour contourner la loi
du coup le gouvernement est loin du
compte et ils avaient prévu que 4
millions de personnes en 2015
bénéficierez de ce smic est en fait pour
le moment on en est pas encore là
et qu'en est il du taux de pauvreté en
allemagne la pauvreté n'a jamais été
aussi élevé en allemagne
plusieurs chiffres sur 80 millions
d'habitants 12,5 millions vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté c'est à
dire avec moins de 892 euros par mois un
autre chiffre depuis 2005 le nombre de
personnes devenue pauvre en allemagne
est dix fois plus important qu'en france
bref selon une étude d'une association
dette sociale le smic ne résoudra pas le
problème il faudrait avoir recours à
l'emploi aidé et ce n'est
malheureusement pas encore au programme
du gouvernement allemand merci cécile
merci non voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci au musée de l'histoire de
l'immigration nous avoir accueilli dans
ses murs nous on se retrouve très vite
sur public sénat et tous les jours sur
publicsenat.fr ciao